gang that state trashy tour is in high
gear talking overtime oh baby yeah do
yourself a favor grab the squad come out
and see the boys Kippy and I co-headline
doing a little standup comedy then we
play a little areu garbage with the
crowd it's a fun fun time yeah next up
are Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Buffalo New
York and then we added a third show in
Toronto get those tickets and we're
going to Pontiac Michigan fourth show
added in Chicago shout out to it then
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee Sacramento
second show outed there San Francisco
San Jose Washington DC date rescheduled
and then Philadelphia Pennsylvania added
a second show with the Filmore get those
tickets gang we love you welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is R you you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they grew up to be classy or if they're
just a big old piece of trash trash
trash trash I'm your host a Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at toies in the new edition she's
upstairs making a pot of her Famous Five
Alarm chili baby okay make your mouth
whistle make your butthole scream all
right okay going dirty early I see my
coost is coming at you from right next
to me son of a [__] [__] stabbing me
in the back he's the CEO of Ru garbage
he's International businessman he's my
best pal in the whole wide world give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody
what up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
true [__] cooking baby uh then what
else did I want to say
patreon.com garbage gang check it the
[__] out it's awesome yes it is and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos threes and the fours he crosses
the te's and he dots the eyes give it up
for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby MCB everybody
what up boys up tone man we got a
Powerhouse in here dude I'd love to see
this guy down in Texas trying to get his
hands on some Gaba goul you know what I
mean gang the long hair ain't lying cuz
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with this today for the first
time he is a very talented actor and
podcaster and you might have seen him in
but not limited to you got Tad paole
Daredevil Law and Order SVU The Dead
Zone Jimmy Kimmel Live Late Show with
David Letterman The View 2010 World
Series of poker the Howard Stern Show
Entertainment Tonight talking Sopranos
where my mom's at your mom's house and
of course he was one of the stars of 76
episodes of one of the most
groundbreaking Emmy award-winning
television shows of all time and he's
got a brand new podcast over there at
ymh Studios with his co-host Jamie ly
Sigler not today Pal give it up for
Robert iser everybody let's go Wow Let's
go I've never heard my full credit I
really haven't I've you got a law and
order in there too
Law and Order you know I got my brother
calling me like you know once a year and
he's like I just saw your Law and Order
like tadpole man nobody I think I've had
one person in my life bring up Tad
that's a great movie yeah yeah wow I
don't I don't I haven't seen it yeah
it's good stuff man buddy thank you for
coming in and sitting down with us yeah
man this is awesome thanks for having me
we're excited give us the uh give us the
backstory give us the origin story New
York kid I grew up in New York City my
whole life uh there were a lot of us in
what they called a one-bedroom apartment
which wasn't cuz there was no door it
was uh you know like a studio type thing
yeah it was like a studio but it kind it
had like another room like a bedroom but
it was not there were uh there were
cockroaches in the bread you know we had
really yeah what neighor what
neighborhood was this uh this was 83rd
between first and second and the only
reason why we lived there is cuz my
grandfather was the Super okay yeah I
lived on 81st and 1st for a while really
right near Gracie M's uh Diner come on
man yeah of great Burgers yeah yeah
Gracie Muse we used to call it the spiz
you meet me at the spiz they would let
us smoke they had the little ashtrays
and they would let us [__] smoke not
even back in the day like well back in
the day but like not a long time ago
there would be like 7:00 a.m. we'd be
smoking in there cuz it like you know
when we were underage there were no like
after hours sometimes that would let us
in and we would just go there and order
like a cheeseburger and a beer and just
then like you know 37 more beers and
just like leave the Burger on the table
just be [__] drinking all night dude
one underrated thing about New York
diners is they serve booze that's great
and it's [__] was awesome you always
forget and then you're there you're like
I'll do a beer and then like cut to and
they like they never take them off the
table so it's like there's always just
like 38 empty beer bottles on and the
craziest selection of liquor they got
Peach Sops and [__] like that wild I
feel like they all just bring it in from
their house every day like what do you
got I got three Sam Adams you know
you're drink you got a drinking problem
which I've done a bunch when you drink
them out of a beer they're like oh we're
out of Budweisers does this work like
just [__] bring it they're like you
want the one that's been on display for
a year and a half on the counter here
yeah
we you know I'd love to ask your guys'
opinions about this we busted my
friend's balls for like 5 years because
so you know when they give the
mozzarella sticks and the lettuce is on
the bottom hate it the worst so we all
you know everybody's eating and whatever
and he he takes the [__] lettuce
rolls it up and then takes the Marinaro
sauce dips it out and eats it one of the
grossest moves I've ever seen to this
day [__] and by the way we like if
you're [__] 60 or 50 it's like one
thing we were like 16 years old can't be
doing that bro get another or like they
have 350 man yeah the menu is 17 Pages
stop eating marinara lettuce that's a go
that's
like that's like eating The
Parsley CRA that's never crossed my mind
to even do that it was he was like in
his glory just doing it and there were
eight dudes just like that's nasty holy
[__] yeah that ain't great holy [__] all
right upper east side your your mom and
dad do that's what we did yeah so my mom
uh ended up eventually working for uh
Transit and then my dad worked at Queen
Center Mall okay you a [__] New York
kid and how many how many were you yeah
so my mom and D this is really New York
so my mom and dad were like 17 or 18
when they had me they weren't even like
they were like barely dating they were
they were they tried to make it work for
a little bit and then uh my dad went off
and he had four kids and then my mom
went off and had one more went right
when I moved out of the house at 18 okay
she had one more DN yeah yeah pretty
pretty wild yeah yikes so you had so
well that age Gap is an 18e difference
between you and your youngest sibling
yeah and then the other ones are like
almost the same there's a there's a set
of twins that are also like that same
age and then my other but but I was yeah
I was I was the only one for like nine
years or something in the in the studio
apartment you and your parents well no
my it was my grandparents place that we
lived at yeah so like my [__] great
grandma who apparently had her own place
but just like lived on in the chair like
she just said smoking she smoked uh so
my grandparents smoked cools and then
she smoked Paul muls and uh never
inhaled and everybody in the family
would be
like whoa I know what that is there's a
missing now you know what that is that's
a test of the emergency broadcast system
on the phone that they were doing oh wow
he [__] goes down is that everybody's
phones going off yeah probably heard
about the lettuce at the time yeah the
emergency system is
functioning uh dirt bag on the upper
side eating orange slices and
parsley so your great so your
grandparents are in the house
grandparent it was their place and then
my my mom and then like my two uncles
would be in and out like it was crazy
man it was like a and we the craziest
part of the whole thing is so the
bathroom was the size of like a locker
like it was so tiny and it was just a
toilet and then the shower was in the
kitchen I've seen that get the [__] out
of here dude we were yeah the 30s yeah
might as well it was [__] pict seen
from Willy Wonka where they're all
laying in bed together yeah yeah yeah
that's what yeah I slept on the I slept
on the couch in the living room with my
grandma and my grandpa it was just like
that holy [__] and you would hear and it
was so terrifying cuz at night all you
would hear was like and you just hear
mice [__] running back and forth on
the and then you'd hear one get caught
on the traps dude it was that was
breakfast holy [__] and then you started
working very young yeah so at like six
years old uh I was walking down the
street with my dad who you know my dad
was like a bigger dude like you know at
the time probably benching like 3:15 he
rides a Harley and like some gay trashy
to quote what your dad was
Ving he was doing he could get 350 one
time he wasn't doing right well that's
all I know about him you know I just but
he he uh he uh the reason I say it is
because he that a gay dude approached us
which in 1990 is different than you know
2020 23 whatever and uh and was like hey
your son is should be an actor you know
and my dad's like what sounds like a
couple of bucks involved in well that's
what happen so so he gives and my and my
dad's like what buddy like what and he's
like no no no I'm I'm I'm a manager I
manage uh you know commercial talent and
actors whatever and he gives my dad a
card and my dad's like what the [__] and
he brought the card back to my mom my
mom's like of course like I knew it you
know saying he's the cutest baby that's
when everybody in the apartment started
dancing and singing around you know I
got a Golden Ticket baby and uh so they
start throwing me on no more mice for us
they start throwing me on auditions and
like pretty pretty quick I got like
Pizza Hut was my first one then I got
IBM AT&T and like things started rolling
Dam National spots yeah yeah W yeah so a
couple of bucks started rolling in yeah
a couple of bucks but uh it's it's like
it's this sounds like a douchy thing to
say say but like I don't even remember
the amount of money because then
eventually Soprano's hit and you're like
oh yeah that you know that was like gas
money compared to [__] you know we're
like a big like Dad what do you need
take it get out of here but my parents
were really great with that stuff like
of not you know but I think they had
passed that law by then where like you
couldn't take the kids money or you
could take up to like 15% or whatever
but um so I I honestly don't know so
that money just goes into any acting
money you make goes into an account in
your name yeah I don't know the r it's
called like the cougan law so I think
the parents can take like whatever 15 or
20% and then I think they could also
take an additional if they want to say
that they're the manager but so what the
end of that story is that guy who was my
man who gave the card is still my
manager today 32 years later great
unbelievable I texted him on the way
here I'm like yo Best Buy's trying to
charge me $200 for something like help
me out cuz that's that's what he like he
literally is like he's the because I
didn't work for 15 years and he's like
yo you keep like you know you still got
checks coming in like what can I do for
you you know and sometimes I'm just hit
him like y Best Buy is trying to charge
me 200 bucks I don't know what to do
with this hey what's he going to do what
are you going to do for you Best Buy
call him up rattle the cages a little
bit he's the best he's he's a gay Jewish
guy and he'll just tell them like hey
they're being [__] Prejudice if if
they don't cancel the thing like he he
gets anything done he's like a fixer
love he's and my all of every actor I've
ever met is like I can't get my manager
on the phone they're like and I'm like
well it's different because I never like
you know people ask their managers for
work and when Sopranos ended I told my
manager don't call me I'm done like I'm
not I'm not doing and I [__] I'm
jammed up at a Walmart
yeah until Apple cares col you know this
Kohl's is trying to screw
me holy [__] that's crazy were you going
to so when how old were you when when
you got the show I was 12 years old and
were you going to were you going to
public school on the upper e side then I
went to public school my whole life
upper e side yeah do you did you go to
school straight through the whole time
you were doing the show no so it's
probably around like seventh grade
eighth grade I was becoming like a bit
of a distraction where like I would show
up twice a week and kind of be you know
just not know what was going on it just
became like a bit of a thing and then uh
eventually kind of awesome a little bit
oh dude I used to show up I used to show
up I used so they used to let us I went
to Wagner on 76 and 2nd they used to let
us out for lunch so I would show up at
lunch at like 11:30 whatever meet
everybody by the [__] mailbox we'd go
out we'd hang out maybe you smoke a
blunt you start drinking and then it's
like do I want to go back in school or
not say you know can I get some people
to hang with me no all right let's go
back to school and then like I just did
it they would sit me down for a test and
I'd be like I can't take that I I don't
know anything that's on here you know
back table in Tony deop yeah oh dude
Tony I used to crush Tony I had I had my
[__] Tony is all right I had my 18th
birthday at Tony dapol downstairs family
style hell yeah [__] love that place
that was the first time I Penny vodka I
[__] blew my mind really which by the
way you guys should be ashamed of
yourselves for trying to make him feel
bad about ordering a pizza for dinner
what the [__] that's cud that's the
biggest SC what what is this are you
garbage or are you the royal family you
can't order a [__] pizza for dinner
it's off
pudding what he doesn't share it it's
unco yeah like all of a sudden we're
gentlemen now I don't even we have a
show about being dirt bags and it's on
the [__] menu you ordered a who
hasn't had a pizza for dinner right not
as an entree at a sit down and I'm a fat
pig yeah I wow that's I it's crazy they
don't budge on it it's insane crazy I
see it constantly all right well we're
cutting
this right now that question if you
haven't ordered a pizza for dinner there
something wrong with you I used to order
this place from delas on 92nd and second
I used to order the same thing every
single day I'd get a large pie half
pepperoni pen aliv vodka and then I'd
get either chicken Franz or uh chicken
marsala and then a salad
extra order garlic knots butter I would
eat that and then I wouldn't eat for
like 36 hours man that's all right I
love a chicken franchise that [__] oh
the one up there is so good man it's so
[__] good and then like cuz I used to
be on such a crazy like partying
schedule once Sopranos ended that it
became like I was living on a not
24-hour clock like I was living on like
a 48 hour clock because I just do
[__] Coke and stay up all night and
whatever so I would just eat once and
then consume just [__] drugs and
alcohol until then I woke up again
feeling like [__] and I was like all
right time to order the load it up yeah
some carbs in you baby you're speaking
my
language oh such good times so you
stayed in school the whole
time kind of kind of and then somewhere
around like 8th grade they were like
okay we'll pay for a tutor for you
full-time so we're cooking now the
show's cooking oh yeah the show yeah
we're yeah there's like uh they say
we'll pay for a tutor for you the whole
time but then like I'd be on set and
everybody else would get 10 minutes to
chill and they'd be like hey come read
two pages of this I was like get the
[__] out of here like I'm not and the
kind of like you know guys like Tony
Sero were like get out of here he's not
reading P you know like they had my back
actual mob guys yeah like I'm like I'm
standing outside a set smoking you know
and like yeah come read this I'm like
get the [__] out of here I got five
minutes of smoke playing dominoes and
[__] yeah the old man in the sea get the
[__] out of here all right what was the
what was so you stayed in were you in
that apartment that whole time too no so
uh so my my grandmother passed we moved
out into a studio on 92nd and second so
my mom got approved for like an income
housing spot so we go 902 and second
even though I think I don't know if that
the time she was working but we were
paying like nothing you know but she
still she moved a friend in and she had
a roommate in a studio apartment it was
like this [__] box I remember her
friend just had like clothes in the
corner were like dude it was [__] I
look back you're living there why the
show's going the show's po no so that's
that's all pre-show once yeah somewhere
around like 10 or 11 we got I don't know
what age but we got approv for a
two-bedroom cuz I'm a uh I was a boy
she's a a woman and when you have a a
woman who has a son you get moved up for
the first two bedroom man the iders are
working the system this dude you are the
most this is the most New York [__] ever
in the lottery we're we're selling our
food stamps 80 cents on the dollar we're
[__] dude we're making moves out here
yeah holy [__] dude crushing it and uh
so so then we had a two-bedroom and it
was like all it went from like living in
these horrible places or to all of a
sudden now I was like I have my own room
like this is crazy and then when I was
most people who were 38 don't have their
own room in New York right yeah exactly
so my uncle uh who was a you know drug
addict I don't know you know the whole
technical thing of like you you always
are a drug addict but you know he
cleaned himself up he's doing great now
but he would steal [__] from me so
somewhere around 10 or 11 I told my mom
like I need a lock for my door So
eventually she got me a lock for my door
with a key because he kept T like I
would come home and be like where are my
video games and it would just be [__]
gone so I got a lock for my [__] door
and that's when like it that's when I
became like a different person can't
tell you [__] the door with a key yeah
and then I got Sopranos and it was like
this guy's Unstoppable he's got a lock
to his room and he's on a [__] hit
show that was it it changed real like
two years everything changed yeah you
get an outside door put on your bedroom
door it's got the hammer on so he could
get stuck in between the two when he
tries to steal something that's awesome
K this is trust and Will shout out to
trust and will I trust them and I will
them let's be honest we all got stuff
that we don't want to do we don't want
to take out the trash we don't want to
clean the litter box but taking care of
your estate is something you don't want
to put off trust and will can help you
with the last one easy peasy there's
simplified the process from finding out
what's right for your family to
finalizing documents and notary yeah I
uh I recently did it I got my Affairs in
order to S I did and you know what what
are you leaving me new guy Luke gets my
collection of
flatbreads no matter what you're
planning for trust and will always has
your back with bank level encryption
there you go it's not out there on the
street all willy-nilly your info will be
kept secure and they have Live Customer
Support to help you whenever you need it
step into a new season knowing that
you're prepared put all that anxiety all
the thought and negative thoughts behind
you hundreds of thousands of families
have used trust and will to plan their
Estates and their five star rating on
trust pilot uh and they're ready to help
you gain peace of mind today with trust
and will get 10% off and free shipping
of your estate planed documents by
visiting trustand will.com garbage
that's 10% off and free shipping at
trustand will.com garbage do it gang do
it this episode is brought to you by
better help oh better help them calling
all weirdos and psychos pres and
accounted for who's losing it huh who's
everybody shut up gang sometimes you all
need to talk things out and talk therapy
is something that can definitely help
you and there's no better place to do
that than better Help Therapy can help
you you figure out what's holding you
back so you can stop worrying and move
forward mhm like I've been telling some
of my
co-hosts big man over here John screw
balls better help is online therapy and
it's incredible uh you can talk to a
licensed therapist through video chat by
phone or even by messaging it's easy
peasy you can do it at your will getting
the help you need has never been easier
I'm using it if you're out there and
you're struggling with you know uh work
life loss of a family anything shoot him
a text hit them on the phone talk
therapy talk therapy is a great tool if
you've used it in the past you know uh
it's tough to get into it's tough to
jump into it's you feel vulnerable it
sucks but with them you just take a quiz
you get match to a licensed therapist
and if you ever need to switch therapist
bada bing bada boom you can change at
anytime no additional charge no
questions this they Ain all they ain't
all up in your Biz uh make your brain
your friend with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com garbage day to get 10%
off your first uh month that's
betterhelp
hp.com garbage betterhelp.com garbage do
it again up back to the show let's go
holy [__] damn okay and was there any
crazy purchases on your end when the
show really start when the checks really
started coming in as a teenager no and
still to this day no I've never owned
anything I've never had a car I've never
had I've never had yeah I'm just like a
New York City rent my apartment anywhere
I go like do you have a license uh I did
I don't think I don't think I renewed it
I think it like expired or whatever but
uh I think goddamn Statue of Liberty
over here this [__] kid if I had to
uh say what my craziest purchase would
be it would be I put myself into the
World Series of Poker when you read the
world I was in the World Series of Poker
but I was playing poker like Main Event
main event and I so 10 grand to get in
10 G 10 grand to get in I won over 40 in
it yeah so it was a [__] made the
money it was a good it was a good
investment but I Wasing two doors yeah I
was playing poker at the time 5 days a
week like I was obsessed with poker so I
was like oh I think this is a good
investment but besides that I probably I
think this is a good as a guy who's was
had a foot in the poker world for a long
time your your judgment gets real cloudy
about Investments yeah but I was I was
better than everyone cuz I didn't have a
[__] job you know what I mean like it
was I was yeah I went I went to Vegas
for two weeks I stayed for a year and a
half holy [__] it was just I was like yo
I'm [__] hanging like what because I
I would go and I'd play and I'd be like
oh my God these guys play like once a
month when their wife lets them and I'm
here playing 5 days a week and and at
the time it wasn't like poker was
figured out so I was just like yo these
guys suck like these guys are awful and
I was just like yeah I'm going to
[__] stay and hang but then I would
drink and lose all the money in other
you know at the [__] strip club or
[__] G betting Sports which is so
dumb but I love what would you say if
you had if you had the guess what' you
drop total in that whole period of
gambling oh I made money really for sure
yeah yeah yeah damn yeah because I had a
hot hand I set things up in a way to not
Lo like I I was okay I can't take out
more than 000 from the ATM so worst case
scenario if I go out [__] party and
my friends are in town this I lose
$1,000 like it's okay we can we can make
that back we'll figure it out but uh
yeah no I definitely I did I did good
like great that's awesome yeah no jet
skis nothing like that nothing ever like
I get like renting that apartment in
Vegas while I still had an apartment in
New York was pretty insane like that was
what was that apartment like uh it was
awesome it when when did you guys when
did you like get like your own own place
so I like the day I turned 18 I moved
out into a [__] hole because I didn't
even like the first place I saw I was
like yep like I was so eager to get out
and then in New York and then I stayed
there for a year and it was probably the
most disgusting apartment you've ever
seen like it was like my family helped
me move and we put all the stuff in and
we're like all right bye and then me and
my friends like sat on the couch started
smoking Blunts and a year went by and it
was just like I know that apartment dude
it was my dresser was in the living room
there's pictures from that apartment in
the living room and my dresser in the
living room and the the the drawers are
[__] falling off I have that same
setup right now oh wow he Liv like he
lives like a rat yeah yeah it was but
the worst part about it was there would
be eight dudes in there at all times
like in and out in and out we started
smoking then everybody starts doing C
and then we're drinking and and then all
of a sudden it just turned into a year
of like non-stop are you are you footing
the bill for your for the your boys
party days too nothing never no because
I most of the time the crazy thing is
once you become famous nobody's charging
you for drinks like you know what I mean
they be like oh you're coming to our
place and then my friends will be like
yo let's [__] go and like so the
first guy they want the free ride Jamie
Lynn had her her birthday at what became
the best club in New York City and I
went to her birthday and the owner said
to me he's like hey man whenever you
want to come back I went alone and he's
like Hey whenever you want to come back
like just come like feel free you know
I'm like okay and uh start moving the
dresser dude the next day I show up with
like six goons like of of [__] from
Uptown and I'm like yeah we're here in
like our North Face jackets and we're
like yeah we're F let's go like what's
up and uh he he lets us all in like you
know six he keeps me at the end and he
goes hey don't ever do this again and I
was like oh okay he goes you come
whenever you want he goes don't do he
goes you bring one buddy when you come
out because it was like yeah it was
insane like it cuz also we were 16
probably 17 at the time or something
getting pizza delivered back there and
[__] dude it looked so now that I think
about it I get like anxiety just
thinking about what I did but I was like
yo the guy said we can go tonight like
you know I'm like know that that young
confidence yeah and the place was like
the hardest place to get in Jack yeah it
was dude it was the and we were like yo
so then every night I'd bring one friend
and yeah they never try people would be
yo come sit our table come sit our table
drugs whatever I [__] wanted like it
was just like oh this is where we're
going every night and that's what I did
holy [__] and there the boys you talk
about they your boys from like childhood
like to K with so my best friend uh
since I was 6 years old I was just last
year the best man in his wedding like
still you know that New York City yeah I
just I need friends who will tell me
when I'm being a [__] [__] and to
go [__] myself and and that kind of [__]
yeah that's all right man that's [__]
wild The North Face jackets is [__]
great dude7 at the club I already
thought you were awesome you
rule you're already I mean it all came
to a screeching halt at 28 spoiler alert
hey that's a decade of good times though
yeah oh yeah man from from 12 I started
drinking and smoking when I was 12 and I
went till till 28 proba had a union
job [__] driving the A
train holy [__] huh all right any uh any
vacations when you were a kid did you
guys go anywhere no I mean there were
times where my dad my dad was more of
the vacation uh guy we would go on a few
like cuz so the woman he married had
family in Florida so we'd get in the car
and drive to [__] Florida Jesus
Christ yeah and then we'd hang there but
they were like yeah stay as long as you
want and hang out so we would crash for
like [__] a week or two and
it got the she had a gallon of iced tea
in the fridge I'm like this lady's the
queen like I'm like this is unreal it
was Crystal Light I remember I never
tasted Crystal and it was just a nozzle
and I would just sit there like a
[__] that my family probably knew I
was going to be a drug addict then cuz I
was just [__] s years old filling up
that Cup drinking it filling up there
like come play in the pool I'm like I'm
good I'm like it's time to fill up the
[__] picture again you know hey
Crystal lights all right crystal yeah so
I just want to understand so the whole
time the show was going on you were in
the two-bedroom with your mom and her
and her roommate yeah no so when we
moved into the two bedroom uh there were
roommates like in and out and people she
moved like three of her friends in at
one time who needed [__] help or
whatever but they're uh eventually by
the time I was the show started 1213 I'd
say for most of that it was probably
just me and her in there and then the
guy who she ended up marrying gotcha
yeah all right so things kind of quieted
down the money was coming in stuff like
that you guys were you guys were in a
good spot the money was coming in but we
lived exactly the same like the money
was just not because in the beginning
the The Sopranos money wasn't a lot it
was probably like somewhere around 16
and started being like okay but still it
was like it was like an unspoken thing
that like my money just went into
account and we lived the same that's
wild smart yeah yeah and then old school
when I was [__] 18 1920 I still lived
the same like my cuz my dad put this
thing in my head of like never use
credit cards it's a scam they're trying
to get you so whatever I I needed to
have on me at all times what I was
willing to to throw
so I never had more than like Max $500
in myet house with grand be like I'm
looking to this yeah and also to me at
the time I had never even seen four
grand you know what I mean when I was
like 18 so I'm like okay like I this is
like I'd be like yo I got five bills in
my pocket this is crazy and then I'd go
out and I'd come home with 700 because
I'd be playing [__] poker at the bar
with somebody or like doing some [__]
and I would like and and never pay for
drinks like I just I dude I never paid
for drink is scheming dude I love it
yeah and that's what's so great about
and [__] play chess in dude I could do
three car Monte right here crush crush
take all his money yeah so the [__]
all right money up boys he's got cash
holy [__] the but the thing that's so
what's great about party drugs is you
never have to [__] pay like Coke I
never paid [__] for Coke now weed and
when I was doing Percocet Percocet was
very different because nobody's like
nobody's giv free per nobody's doing
three per perc at parties you know what
I mean like it that was a thing where it
was like like like I'm doing perets I
got to do this it was a quieter thing
the pills were a quieter thing yeah
where Coke was like oh yeah the Coke's
over there you know me and my friends be
like oh my God these guys just leave
[__] Coke out like this is insane and
then weed weed is 5050 like you know if
you're partying some people just hand
you weed whatever but it wasn't the same
as like Coke in New York City was like
anywhere we went it was just there like
free Coke like it was crazy alcohol too
alcohol not for everybody just so you
know that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
two had cocaine addictions at about the
same time probably with very different
stories right yeah yeah yeah try it now
try it now I bet you get free Coke
now holy [__] man that's [__] old
school H that's dude I that's so
different than what I imagined that's
crazy uh any injuries as a kid you break
anything broke my arm uh yeah two bones
right here and then I cracked my head
open up here on my bike and uh yeah this
this was crazy
this was crazy too and then because my
my mom didn't want me to have surgery so
they just they had to place it and then
put a cast on me like forever so I still
look how crazy this is so you know you
can go like this and you should be able
to do that with the other hand my hand
goes like this whoa what the [__] yeah
yeah like an action figure this is like
my full range of motion with this where
this like I can do this but this is it
because they just they said it and then
they [__] put it in a place how old
were you when this happened so that I
think was like right before Sopranos me
maybe maybe 10 or n or I know I was it
was after like 8 and before Sopranos
between 8 and 12 around there Jesus what
kind of bike were you rocking back then
yeah oh just like a little whatever was
like a little bicycle I don't even I
don't even remember what it was okay
whatever like probably they went to Toys
R R Us and it was like the first one
that was yeah like all right that's
29.99 like all right let's go yeah what
uh what age did you start riding the
Subway by yourself
uh Subway I don't know but we were
walking to school alone at like [__]
7even eight were you hop into Subway
would you would you jump to Turn Style
no we weren't big Subway guys because we
always stayed up town got like yeah we
were always neighborhood guys like you
said Yorkville was like always what we
like we had clothing that's said like
York some kid made like Yorkville
clothing and we all rocked it and like
Yorkville but it was like Hey meet us at
the park and the lowest we would go
would be like John J Park one of my
friends lived on uh like 60th so we
sometimes we go to him but like
otherwise you never go past that that's
such a New York thing it's so big but
you're like your life is 12 blocks yeah
west side yeah dude never they don't
cross over never go through the park at
this time of the day now that I'm
[__] 38 when I come here I'm like I
want to go to Central Park I walk around
I'm like I can't believe this was here
the whole time no idea it's [__]
bugged out cuz we I'd say unless I was
doing like little league baseball for
the couple years I did it I would I
never stepped foot in Central Park it
was probably a different park at the
time time too right there was in the 90
in the early 90 it wasn't great right no
but it was yeah it wasn't one of those
things where you're like during the day
like n you could cuz we used to hang out
till [__] 2 a.m. at Carl Schulz down
on uh 86 Street in East End we would be
in there like at with the [__] two
blocks from the mayor's Mansion throwing
in like [__] everybody bring 240s and
we just you know there would be 40 of us
sometimes yeah and that's the same park
where my mom and my dad met when they
were [__] 17 you know that's crazy
yeah when I when I lived up here the
first time we were I was on the lived on
the upper side 81st and 1st I worked at
83rd and3rd at this place called
martel's on the corner and we never left
I didn't learn the subway and I stayed
in New York for 10 years then moved to
Philly started doing comedy then we
moved back in 2013 then I learned the
subway I never knew how to get anywhere
because we were just up there what was
Martell's Martell was it was an Irish
Bar corner 83rd and third oh wow okay
yeah it was all right it was a good time
so my my grandfather was in Brady every
single day which is 80 83rd and second
or 82nd and second or whatever and like
Quinn's daughter or Ryan's daughter or
something like that was up around that
up by there yeah it was all right
Italian place for ens was around the
corner yeah my my grandfather would go
there every single day from work for
lunch and never go back to work so they
they would have like free sandwiches for
the guys at like 12 go everybody would
go have sandwiches and then just you're
supposed to go back to work from like
whatever 1 to 3 four five and just like
nobody's [__] was getting fixed after
that he was was so he was a porter on
actually he was a porter on I maybe 83rd
and third okay you know right off a
third the building with the awning yeah
there was the hu the huge building
across the street my so my grandfather
was the porter there and then he was the
Super of our building yeah yeah yeah and
he would walk down to Brady every single
day and that's where I would go to
[__] meet him damn that's wild yeah
yeah and they would put like 40 marcino
cherries in a cup and I would just sit
at the end of the bar and I'd be buzzing
by the time I left that kid likes his
sugar I remember I I put in my first uh
parlay I must have been like seven years
old yeah and my grandfather so my
grandfather [__] jacked up on olives
give me the Jets in the over yeah I
loved D Marino at the time and I'm like
I want the I want the Dolphins I told
him and he's like all right I'm like you
know whatever I I want to put 10 bucks
or 20 bucks that I got for like my
birthday or some [__] and he's like okay
and then I lost and I gave him the 20
and he was like The Vig and I was like
what is that and he's like that it's an
extra thing you got to give on top when
you lose and I was mad at him for weeks
it was like it was like 20 and then
extra yeah yeah yeah cuz he put the bed
in yeah put theed in coming out of his
head yeah yeah plus you owe me for the
cherries holy [__] dude that's crazy
what was the where were you getting 40s
did you have a fake idea or would you
have I assume a spot that you're like
they play ball we had a spot that played
ball but then we would also make friends
with like the homeless guys around there
and be like yo if you buy us all [__]
we'll buy you yeah exactly so there this
guy named Sarge uh who like still
thought he was in the you know the war
or whatever and he would always buy us
uh [__] you know and then he'd get too
drunk and like disappear and be like yo
where go but there's a place right on
like 87th and 1 or was it York 87th like
right around there that would that would
usually be all right with us but then
like somebody would go in there drunk at
like one night and [__] steal [__]
from there and then and then they and
then they would wouldn't [__] be nice
to us anymore it was like always a
[__] push and pull yeah for a while
they were really good those BOS if you
if you if you got to know them they were
good good with like credit and stuff
like that they let you run up a little
bit of a tab hell yeah next time yeah of
course yeah those guys and my my
favorite thing like I remember I was
dating this girl from London at one time
and she came to stay with me here and
I'm just sitting on the couch and I
reach for my phone I grab it I pick it
up I'm like hey I'm like what's up buddy
and I don't even say anything else I go
yeah uh like you know four packs of
maror Lights two six packs of Corona and
then I hang up and she's like what was
that and I'm like oh I ordered from the
deli M she's like you can do that here
and I'm like you can't yeah it's a very
new New York thing dude it was the I
would Doge yeah I would do that [__] and
he was open 24 hours whenever you want
to call what that and that was like from
I lived on that spot from like 19 to
whatever 28 or whatever I would just
call him constantly he was my boy
there's one down in uh the East Village
that it's next to a comedy club and you
go in it's right on the corner you know
[__] second and whatever and it's a
great Bodega but they're so mean because
all of their business is just delivery
so like it's just like a warehouse for
them and you're in their way they don't
want to [__] ring yeah it's not the
same they treat you like such [__]
[__] when you walk in there yeah
what did you call your grandparents what
were their what were their names Pop and
Grandma nothing nothing great yeah it
was just pop uh what was your first
concert but his nickname was Buster
sorry because at the bar they said he
was like the biggest ball buster that's
awesome yes they called him Buster uh
what did you say what was my first
concert first concert mom took me to
Rolling Stones no [__] at [__] uh old
meti so what was giant Stadium at
[__] giant Stadium awesome and I
think it was she only did that I think
because my dad was like I'm taking
Robert to Van Halen at Jones Beach and
she was like you're not taking him to
his first [__] concert and she was
like come on you're coming with me and
we went to [__] Rolling Stones and I
remember being like yo this is [__]
sick like it was dope man huh what was
still made the van hland show the next
night play both ends against the middle
what was the last concert you went
to
uh that's tough man I don't know ever
since I got sober I'm like I can't I
can't do anything being around group I
went to the Giants game on Monday nice
but where did I yeah [__] they got
crushed but uh where did I what's the
last man that's
tough I don't know it's been a while I I
went through a phase when I was like you
know what I did use Sopranos as leverage
for for sure is like when 16 to 22 I was
or whatever 16 to 18 I was really into
like uh heavy metal death metal all that
stuff see [__] panta slip knot I'd be
[__] backstage with them hanging out
and that was the [__] that was the
best that was the only question I wanted
to ask you about the show did you keep
the slip knot jacket did you steal that
they so the reason why I was wearing all
that stuff on the show is because I was
wearing it in real life okay so I would
have all that stuff in real life and
David Chase would [__] see me not
that he needed any help he's a [__]
genius but he would see me [__] with
a [__] panta shirt or whatever and
then a couple weeks later my character
would be wearing uh that was all right
yeah that thing was tight have you been
around slipnot like after a show they
pull the mask off and they're like seong
was a little it's got to be so bizarre
they were the best so the first time I
ever went to a slipnot show I I don't
remember how well it was 1999 maybe so I
maybe so I'm 14 and we roll up outside
and I meet Shawn who's the clown who was
one of the drummers and he's like uh
he's like yeah come on let's go in and
we go to walk in and they're like no
he's [__] 14 it was at the Roxy I
think you have to be maybe 18 2 I don't
know so they go he's not coming in and
he goes to the guy he goes well he's my
son so if he's not coming in we're not
playing and like right away which he
probably done you know over and over but
like he's like you know so we're not
playing the guy's like all right like
opens the [__] rope and me and my boy
walk in he brings us backstage and there
and this is like before they were
massive so they're all sitting in one
room that's like half the size of this
and it's like [__] what is there
eight of them or nine I can't even
remember nine cuz zero or some [__] and
they were just hanging and they would do
a thing before it shows where they would
flip for punches so they take a quarter
and you call heads or tails and whatever
it lands on punch the other one in the
face Jesus nuts dude these guys were
nuts you're seeing this at 14 yeah yeah
and and I was like oh my God this just
opened up my hor and then I'm like I'm I
I re because I there was Road Runner
records they were all on at the time and
I the people there started sending me
clothes and all the stuff CU they found
out that I was a fan and then it was
just like you know I'm hanging out with
all these guys I'm going to [__]
dysfunctional family picnic and
announcing bands and like all this [__]
crazy man yeah and the whole time I have
like $6 in my
pocket really no no credit card I'm like
I think about it now I'm like how the
[__] did I get around like it's just
crazy what did you what did your parents
say when when you were doing that what
did you tell them you were like I said I
had the lock on the door I I'm [__]
I'm making money like there was no I was
and they were city kids so they
understood like you know by by 14 a city
kid is like
25 I was walking to school by my own
like I said what seven eight so like
there was no you know you're taking cabs
by yourself all that kind of stuff just
zipping around yeah but again we we
really stayed Uptown like you know like
you could almost always find me 10
blocks from my crib like I I was never
somebody who was like Hey guys let's go
to [__] Worcester Street like you
know I I didn't even know downtown like
I really didn't like it was such an
uptown kid thing said oh what the street
yeah I never knew any like I still I
come downtown sometimes and I'm like I
don't know where like cuz it's like as
soon as the numbers stop you know they
got buildings and [__] down there too
yeah huh okay wild what's your favorite
restaurant in New York oh yeah let's
talk a little bit about that it depends
what we're what we're just o open-ended
like anything or you're coming into town
for one night you're like I got any you
can get any I mean Don Pep's and queens
but it's not in the city but it's in
Queens but Don peps and queen Italian is
[__] outstanding but it's also a Vibe
like it's like Cas only this but all JG
melons is [__] great SEC third a
those Burgers those B and also like
that's like walking into a tie machine
dude it's the best little [__] the
little chip french fries oh my cottage
fries un [__] and you go like what's
so great about this you I don't know but
it's just perfect like the burger the
everything it's the attitude on the
waitress the [__] old Bartender the
wood on the bar my God and then they had
I remember bringing a girl to [__]
Jackson Hole when it was on Second
Avenue and she ordered a chicken
sandwich I was like we're done remember
how big those Burgers wear a Jackson
Hole they were crazy yeah M massive
crazy yeah man they were all right but
you said you're a little bit of a foodie
yeah yeah now I've you know ever since I
got sober and then all of a sudden I
started [__] watching food
documentaries and I'm like all right I
want to stay away from this I want to
stay away from that I'm you know [__]
I want to eat organic as much as I can I
cook my own food now I'm like very you
know I start like somebody just again
it's like it's like the things that
unlocked when I was young where I was
like what like somebody was like so when
I got sober it was my 28th birthday I
took 35 Molly and I was just up for but
I had build been building up a tolerance
for years like living in Vegas and [__]
Jesus Christ yeah and when I when I was
done with that session I remember
thinking I did permanent damage to
myself like I was like oh man like I did
it this time not bouncing back from this
yeah and I was like if I get out of this
uh I'm done like I'm not going back and
that was over 10 years ago and uh I did
I I [__] like five six days later I
went to a doctor I'm like yo I can't
hold down any food like I'm just a mess
like I don't know what's going on and
he's like when's the last time you had a
vegetable and I'm like oh and chicken
fried rice they put [__] you know I mean
like I had a cup of noodles there's some
peas and carrots in there yeah I'm like
I so I have that and the guy looked at
me like I was insane I some lettuce with
marinara we we hate on people for eating
[__] vegetables around here doc I uh
but yeah so I and he's like hey he's
like go and he told me eat vegetables
but he goes go to this place and get a
green juice and I'm like come on dude
and he's like you haven't kept anything
down for over 5 days he goes go and do
it and see how you feel and I [__]
drank this juice and I came out of place
and I was like I think I'm on ecstasy
like I felt like I was on ecstasy like
cuz my body had nothing in it for five
days and had nothing in it like no
nothing good like all I ate was chicken
fingers french fries Pizza Burgers until
I was you know 28 still do that yeah I
never nothing wrong with a chicken
figure I was 30 before the first time
where somebody was like forced me to try
fish you know like I was like okay yeah
I had like tuna sandwiches growing up
never anything at a restaurant where and
now I'm like holy [__] you do oysters
and stuff like that now you like I'll do
sushi do sushi I'll do sushi but still
on the oyster [__] I'm like n that's
that's crazy shrimp crab Lobster you
like that stuff no I'm still not on that
I'm like a salmon tuna like this kind of
thing I like [__] Branzino nice a
nice brino
yeah let's go uh what's uh this is a
thing we talk about we've have talked to
Tom about it what's the biggest thing
you've dropped on a dinner at like a
nice like you've gone out anything crazy
yeah I mean I so I remember uh actually
when I was in well I don't know if this
is the biggest but like a two person
dinner for sure with no drinks uh I was
dating this girl and she came to meet me
in Austin before I moved there when I
went to go visit Jamie and she gets off
the plane she meets me at my place we
bang and then
we and we're like we're we had like we
had an 8:00 pro move bang before dinner
only only especially I only eat once a
day so I'm always a snake who
does so we have had an anope earlier we
have sex I
shed we uh so we we we bang I we go and
we had I won't use the no I bang yeah
stuck that in there pretty good well
because we were ravenous that's what I'm
trying to say we got to the we got to
the restaurant and we and it was like a
sushi place uh first time I had it now
it's like my favorite place to go to it
was like 600 bucks for just the two of
us no drinks that's big for two for two
people two people no drinks no booze all
right yeah yeah 600 it was I was like
damn especially when like you know we're
eating things that are [__] every
it's like one bite at a time and all of
a sudden the check comes like [__]
600 off I only got eight bucks on me
yeah somebody gave me three car Monte
yeah but again sorus was 52,000 52,000
he wrote it down and we framed it it's
on the bar right there he didn't want to
say it out loud and then he couldn't he
slid it over to W I'm asking for a race
when I get back to Austin Tom just so
you know it was a birthday it was a
large it was a large table he said whose
birthday it was his I think it was his
okay I think it was maybe his four it
was it was a big birthday for him Ando
they said he's like it yeah they run it
out I think it was like a 30 person it
was like a a big thing they run out the
whole restaurant yeah I mean 52 said
maybe it was just him chrisa I don't
know 52 G's that's that's why almost
came off I
I yeah I did one time in LA go to a
dinner for um I mean now this sounds
like nothing but I went to this special
dinner that was like I don't know how
many people it was but it was like a
$30,000 dinner where like every course
they came out with and they described oh
this is then they like custom made so
they asked the two people who were
throwing the dinner like what they want
and then they C like she said her
favorite
um meal was a fish fillet from
McDonald's so they made like this like
aight verion of that and they're like
the in the in the tartar sauce is 50
gram of blah blah blah Cav and they're
like telling you all the [__] and and
I'm like like you I'm just sliding that
[__] over to my boy I'm like I don't
want that [__] but yeah it was it was
really you a real one dude it was really
[__] it was nice and it was it was
fancy it was cool yeah okay [__] damn H
man all right do some more you garbage
cues here yeah uh you flossing every day
uh no I I have the sticks so it helps a
lot but I certainly if it was string I
would never floss but with the sticks I
I get in there when there's something in
there I get in there that's how I I go
about you know if I if I'm eating
[__] cashews I'm going with the stick
I'm going with the stick what about the
toothpaste what are you using you trying
to stay organic on all that stuff yeah I
try now I try and get everything from
Whole Foods I try and go real us Toms
yeah Tom but so I have two I have the
toms with the
aluminum extra aluminum no the uh what's
the stuff that's in there not [__]
[__] what's floride bide with fluoride
and one without because I think when you
do all no without fluoride your breath
starts to stink so I got I got yeah I
got the fluoride that I use uh during in
the morning and then I got the no
fluoride I use at night okay unless I'm
dating at the time then I go with the
fluoride are you getting the Whole Foods
delivered you go are you going and food
shopping at Whole Foods uh I so I didn't
discover like Whole Foods delivery I
don't know if it was like Co or right
before where I was like holy [__] but I
don't like it I love to [__] stroll a
[__] Whole Foods man I I love to read
[__] ingredient I like to know what's
going on yeah unless and there's
sometimes where like you have to do an
order but normally um I I love being in
a [__] Whole Foods are nice did you
say so you don't drive no so how you get
how you getting around down there Uber a
lot I lot too I'm a big walk guy like I
I'll walk five six miles really just to
go somewh yeah because I just I love
walk I'm in New York City like I love
walking man but I've never heard anybody
so you'll Uber Texas with no car you'll
Uber to Whole Foods yeah no walk to
Whole Foods I'm within walking distance
walk it back yeah I usually walk back
unless it's like a big shop then I'll
Uber back huh I've never heard anybody
using an Uber for to move groceries yeah
and they and they will say like I've
taken Uber to uh uh Whole Foods before
if I'm like coming from somewhere and
they're like you want me to wait for you
like so they they do it they know the
deal yeah and I'm like no I'm going to
be in here for 3 hours I got a lot of
reading you make your bed in the morning
and you know I never did and I think it
was like Jordan Peterson was on Rogue
likey if want to be out there
talking I do he's like you at least need
to [__] clean your own room you know
make your bed do this so I started doing
that and um I'm one of those people
where like a OCD where like I did it
once and now it's been four years I've
never KN now you do it and what's the
house like down there you got a nice
setup uh no I got a one-bedroom with
nothing in it so like my my buddy said
um my place looks like one of Jason
Bourne's fake Apartments sure you got go
bag three passports a handgun like I
have the bag I came here with I got a
[__] uh that is dude that is like an
old school spy bag you rolled you never
know when you got to go bro I got the
[__] uh I got I got the TVs I got the
bed I got the couch there's nothing else
in my apartment multiple TVs uh I got
one in the bedroom one in living room
yeah yeah what's the bed is it a king
size uh no Queen okay yeah man can't get
a read on this guy I know wild um what
do you keep your butter at the house
keep it in the fridge or keep it on the
counter uh I have one in each how about
that that's CL no one has that because I
like the cold for the the pan when I'm
cooking and I like the spreadable when I
want to spread nice salted on the
outside uh I do all my own salt I don't
want their salt I do my own salt yeah I
do unsalted butter and then I add my own
salt dude I'm I'm a lunatic when it
comes the sea salt on the top is that
how you do it yeah yeah yeah so whatever
whatever I put the butter on then I hit
it with the I got the grinder sea salt
you got the power grinder or you got the
the regular crank so I I got the power
grinder and it didn't work for the sea
salt but it works for the pepper so I
power grind the pepper hand grind the
salt I got answers for whatever whatever
question you [__] got you got the
morar and
pestl like the is that what it's called
the mortar and P Mort and pestl more
like it's like the rock B like no no no
like for crashing up walnuts or yeah
yeah like for uh uh how they make what's
the avocados guac
what is that called mortar Mor pest wow
mortar and pestl sounds like a bad Law
Firm we'll lose for you this is big on
the show when you go to the deli counter
uh do you get your meat sliced thin and
I also what's the level of recognition
from Deli guys you receive uh it it
totally depends where I am it totally
and also like when I was in New York
going to my delies they don't give a
[__] cuz I go in there every day but I
you know I remember the first time I
went to Italy you know [__] Italy and
I got got online to get like [__]
sliced meats or whatever and there's
somebody in line I get in line behind
and I'm like oh I'm I'm like waiting a
long time cuz they're like going on and
on and somebody comes from outside the
back and they see me and they run to
grab like a piece of paper and I'm like
oh you know I'm like guy's coming to get
an autograph all right yeah it's an
Italian place I get it BL and he comes
running from behind the thing and with a
paper and he hands it to me and it's
like a piece of prute like to give me P
because I felt bad that I was waiting in
line so now I've never been so sad to
get a piece of Pou cuz I'm like I'm like
I'm such a tool like I think put your
sunglasses on yeah like I'm like I'm
such a tool I thought this guy was like
rushing to get an autograph but he was
just like oh he felt bad cuz I was
waiting there the guy had like stacks of
fight he was doing like a wine and
cheese night in front of me aren't you
the guy from slipnot
son holy [__] you ever have a Lunchable
yeah yeah back in the day okay for sure
yeah disgusting now I would never never
touch it no no no you guys would you
guys eat Lunchables now no never well
that's crazy
maybe for I was never a big lunchable
guy um what kind of what foods do you
have at the house like what do you keep
on hand so I just it's it's depressing
no hold on no couch yeah yeah I said c I
got the couch couch bed two t it's like
the two TVs here couch here bed here
that's it there's nothing else same room
no no no so it's on on opposite ends of
the wall so the two TVs are on that wall
and that separates the got got got got
there is literally oh the only other I
have in there I finally got a [__]
Roomba awesome man I can't freaking quit
bragging will you all right saying that
saying that like it's 2003 ARA does it
for
you okay so what what kind of food do
you have in like if we came over right
now I'm like hey I'm hungry what do you
got it it's literally like salmon from a
specific origin like you know I'm like
really high in because I I now I don't
like to feel like [__] ever since I've
crossed over into like not abusing like
up until like 28 to [__] because then it
took me a couple years to get off the
pills but like at 28 I stopped the
drinking and then like all of a sudden I
remember like waking up and being like
Oh I feel good when I wake up and like I
had never felt that since I was I don't
know 10 even maybe even before because I
was always eating such garbage like
horrible never had any sort of like hey
maybe eat some protein like you know it
was just I was eating so bad growing up
and um around 30 I started realizing
like oh my God if I eat good I feel good
and then and then like you know now it's
and also it's like I have nothing else
to do but be healthy like you know I I I
didn't work for [__] years I don't
have a family like like I don't have a
wife a kids so it's like oh this is all
I got to do and and you know the rare
occasion where I eat like [__] the next
day I'm like what is [__] wrong with
you like I just feel terrible what's a
typical order at Whole Foods what what
are you dropping couple Hy yeah oh at
least yeah I I go uh but now what I've
started because I do the walk what I've
started doing is I order chicken and
fish from like one of these you order it
it shows up at your door uhhuh kind of
place so I fill the [__] freezer with
that and then my yeah my my my fridge is
just like always the same [__] like you
know it's like [__] lemon juice lime
juice lettuce like mustard like you know
I don't have you like a Trader Joe's you
a Trader Joe's man no I heard bad I
heard conspiracies about Trader Joe's
that got in my head this guy's nuts yeah
oh dude I'm nuts when it comes to food
I'm cra and that's that's probably the
hardest part about datings when I'm
dating somebody like I've I've talked to
girls where I go like I'm like oh this
is going good and then all of a sudden
like she's like yeah I just get
McDonald's every day on the way home I'm
like we're done really when was the last
time you had fast
food years oh my god really yeah yeah
like over five years good for crazy I
haven't had anything fried in years like
no french fry no I'm dude I'm so when
you go out to dinner now it's it's super
limited no because you again once you
start eating fish it changes everything
like before I before I eat before I atat
fish I'm like you can't eat anywhere and
be healthy now I'm like oh my God I
could just eat [__] fish so usually
because I only eat once a day I'll I'm
like a multiple entree kind of guy where
I'll be like all right I'll get the
[__] salmon and the bronzino and the
[__] this or you know really School
efficient Lun dude I I put back like my
one meal I mean so you know the first
season The Sopranos I was like 200 lb I
was a [__] big I was a real big kid I
love to eat man so I that's why I eat
once a day cuz like there's no diet for
me that's sustainable because I I don't
feel pleased gotcha so I just eat that
once a day I eat a [__] ton of food
and like when I go to I go to Jamie's
house every Sunday in Austin and I'll
eat and then with her family and then
her family has dessert then they start
doing like their after dinner activities
then they give the kids a bath this they
come out I'm still eating like I'll I'll
eat for minimum two hours can she throw
down in the kitchen is she a good cook
she's a good cook ni yeah she's a she's
a good cook when you eat at the
restaurants are you telling them let me
get the salmon just give me a broil no
sauce or nothing like that no I I try
not to be a pain but also like I so
you'll get the dish whatever it is yeah
but I also will vet spots you know what
I mean where like if I see they're doing
something insane I'm like all right I'm
not [__] I'm not I'm not going to do
that so you're not doing like the ber
Blanc sauce over the over the S the
mashed potatoes like no no no if I if I
like I went to have steak the other
night and it was just [__] salt
pepper that's all I want and they're
like we'll put the sauce like I don't
want any [__] sauce just [__] give
me a good steak salt pepper I'm good man
I could I could eat rice protein salad
just for [__] every meal but then
after is when I like treat myself I
start I have like [__] oh I have like
weird [__] after I eat like I'll have
[__] oatmeal and I have these things
called like um honey Mamas and just like
all this kind of like chocolatey stuff
that's made with like honey [__]
people see her up in like that's Whole
Foods has all that [__] you know so I
just [__] go crazy what about the uh
Barbecue in Austin love yeah I'll I'll
hit those spots but in my head I go
these guys get the meat from like a good
Farm or whatever but I yeah like like
you know couple times a year I'll crush
and really [__] enjoy it and then so
the the place I the sushi place that I
spent all the money at that I go all the
time now it's like the [__] my
favorite spot they opened up a
restaurant with the best barbecue chef
and it's like a Asian smok house oh my
God nuts when you go when next time you
guys go to Austin you go to Loro it's
called Loro it's [__] great we went
there and we yeah we went there you
didn't like it no do we not like it we
didn't stay that's the place where you
walk in you order at the bar yeah yeah
and it's like there oh yeah I dipped
inside and outside you didn't like the
yeah well it was crazy hot we were down
there a couple weeks ago it was like
117° yeah we yeah we got a table we
thought it was going to be more Korean
barbecue like sit down and have uh and
then the dude came over and like go to
the bar I was like yeah we're out of
here oh you missed out man it was also
packed the food is [__] awesome but I
thought you were talking about the the
the couple the the the chefs that have
the they're like a Michelin star Chef
they had a sushi place but they also
opened up that burger place that we went
to with Bobby Le um it's a really good
burger place in the back of a bar nordak
or something like that back of some Club
she has a famous pasta she has a famous
pasta place I forget so we [__] up not
going to that place yeah yeah that place
is really everything you cuz it's like
it's like barbecue mixed with Asian
which is [__] awesome like it's just
everything you're like holy [__] this is
[__] great do you know how to use
chopsticks I learned once I started
eating sushi I'm still not good like I'm
not confident but I can get by but like
I still you know I get fatigued about 10
minutes into the meal where like not gra
good yeah where it's and that's why like
what's cool is when you go to these like
really upscale uh sushi places you're
supposed to eat with your hands your
hands yeah so I'm like I'm I'm I'm
culturally appropriate that's what I
tell you know so I'm not using the
[__] sticks I'm not using the stick
sck uh do you own any
binoculars uh no but I think my my
friend's mom got me them as like a
birthday gift or something so there
might be a pair floating around
somewhere that's a weird it's a weird
present from your buddies mom I know
dude it happened you know I love her
she's the best she you know she's a a
saint that's awesome are you currently
in a beef with a
neighbor uh no no very when I was 18 and
I had that place I had the ultimate beef
with a neighbor I'm sh I'm sure they
loved you yeah it was bad the guy would
throw beer bottles from his place
upstairs he was a nut too it wasn't like
he was some Saint and then what's crazy
is when so he I moved out when I was 19
the person who owned the building called
me when I was like 22 I was like hey if
you want to move back in here he died
and I'm like okay like I was just so
moved on at that point I'm like what
like but okay and and then I found out
from her son that the guy had no family
no friends left and he wrote on his wall
I leave everything to and it was the per
it was the woman at the massage place
around the block the Asian massage place
and he left everything to that lady he
wrote it on the wall damn yeah man what
a way to go [__] and you throw [__]
beer bottles constantly at us I mean you
were probably raging down there it was
bad yeah smoking blun blasted all night
and S yeah yeah yeah that double base
alone they got nine drummers at [__]
yeah yeah I'm surprised the guy didn't
kill us ever swam in a
river uh yeah I'm sure I mean I don't
even you go to Barton Springs down there
take a dip I haven't been yet but I want
to go oh it's all right try to make it a
point to go every time we're there oh
wow feels good the best city attraction
anywhere in America really awesome yeah
it's the coolest Standalone thing it no
other place has something like that it's
cool it's close yeah it's tight I've
walked by but I never went in I should
go in yeah it's all right man okay yeah
it's good nice and cool the water and
what do you recommend there going for
like making a day out of it you pop for
a dip hour two yeah just go jump take
swim jump off the diving board and
there's a place to like put a towel and
lay down when you dry off it's like a
little Hill okay yeah it's all right
it's a good time you do cold plunges or
I tell them you sent
me remember those fat idiots down here
dude I almost broke the diving board
there I swear to God it [__] like
almost touched the water I was so
[Laughter]
do you enjoy any of these smells asphalt
gas horses or magic marker horses I
don't even remember but uh gas is the
best yeah love gas g this guy likes red
lining dude yeah yeah yeah I'm a big gas
guy but but on the other end of that I
love laundry you like smell fresh
laundry oh my God but not the candle
like the fake [__] I want like walking
by a laundry man I'm like oh my God yeah
that when it's blowing out
we just caught that last night there was
the they we walked by the hotel and the
garage door was open they were doing the
laundry and it was such a New York
moment the [__] it just hit you way
the fluff and fold in New York the way
that SM whatever they use it's probably
the worst thing for you but that smells
so good it's whatever they were putting
in those envelopes sending to people
after
911 are you doing your laundry now are
you sending it out what are you doing
yeah so um again one of my OCD things is
like I get a little crazy about the
germs cuz I used to just hand so long
story short I got an STD in my early 20s
and ever since then I it just changed
who I am like I just I'm like I don't
want to get [__] because I so I got
an STD and I I called a doctor thinking
like CU like I I didn't know at the time
of anything so many STDs I'm like I just
have AIDS and I'm dying like that's what
you think you go there yeah right and
I'm like oh my God so I called the
doctor and he's like okay yeah you could
come in like next Wednesday so I was
like I ain't got that kind of time I'm
just sitting there like just dripping so
thinking like I'm dying I'm I'm writing
on my wall who leaving my [__] too you
know I'm like this is it for me like I'm
I'm a goner and then I get there and
they do
thege yeah and he's like well he's like
here's the thing what I could see what
you have is blah blah blah and he's like
50% of people have that like it happens
all the time everyone in college has it
he's I give you this shot in the ass
he's like but then and this is where it
[__] this is what's stuck with me he
goes I got to stick this Q-tip oh yeah
in there get some stuff send that off
and I'll find out if it's anything more
serious so now it's another [__] in 2
weeks yeah I'm sitting at home and I'm
wa and after getting a Q-tip stuck in
the head of my it was just so bad and
that was one of those other things where
I was like if I get through this like
I'm up yeah like I'm I'm not [__] you
know being uh crazy so now with with my
laundry yeah I don't trust it because I
used to just yeah whatever like I there
was a guy in the building I grew up in
you [__] your socks what are you
doing there was a guy in the building I
grew up with named Vinnie who would [__]
in the washer he would [__] in the
washing machine and never you know as a
kid I'm like oh yeah whatever like you
know they' [__] shut one down use the
other ones or whatever and as a kid I'm
like whatever now I'm like I can't so
I've been in New York for a couple of
weeks and I hit up my friends I'm like
yo can I come use your [__] thing cuz
I can't go to a public I do understand
that I don't I don't hate that I have I
very similar with germs and stuff like
that but I have with them with the drop
off and pickup I have a kind of out of
sight out of- mind thing I'm like it's
better than the ones in my building I
don't have one in my unit so I'm like
just [__] if I can't see it I'm
assuming they're using the cleanest
machine and we're going to move forward
and you live in the city now [__] in the
laundry what the [__] yeah oh they were
CRA dude in my [__] building growing
up there were some wild dudes wild dudes
using the organic stuff in in the in the
laundry yeah I love it yeah yeah Seventh
Generation what are you using uh or uh
Seventh Generation but so I'll use like
the Whole Foods brand or whatever
whatever they got that's like a [__]
Yellow Tag you know on sale or what I'm
not I'm not big about what it is I'm
just like I want to know that there's
not like poison in here hopefully you
know um you ever bought the floor model
of a TV or an
appliance I know I bought the floor
model of something one time when they
like you could have this one and it was
whatever but I can't remember what it
was I don't think it was a TV uh no so I
I never bought a nice TV until I moved
to Austin because and and guess what
it's [__] lost on me I don't get it
like all my TVs before that were like
$300 [__] I'm kind of the same way
yeah and then so like I when I moved to
Austin I was like you know what I'm
going to do the nice thing and it was
like a $5,000 TV on sale for 2500 and
the guy's like oh do this I'm like all
right I'm going to do it and I look at
it I go I am garbage cuz I'm like I
don't know the difference between this
yeah I go I don't know the difference
between this and every other TV I'm the
same way yeah I don't get it the value
of spending an extra $3,000 to the $500
TV yeah and also it's like what am I
watch it I'm not [__] you know what I
mean like I watch I watch junk like I
watch [__] reality TV and [__] what
do I need to like pixels you watch
reality TV a lot yeah yeah I'm a big
90day fiance hit me dude oh my God are
you watching the ones that are on right
now on H Max SP man I know it's like
he's like I have my own sea salt pepper
grinder I love Pitbull pits and parolis
um uh what one's on now not on H I don't
know I watch it on my it's on demand so
there's uh they've gotten crazy cuz now
there's like shows within shows there's
the watch alongs there's women on their
second or third it's definitely too many
do you know the one that's on now is one
of them is is with the guy with the hat
who won't take it off and he's with the
smoking hot Spanish chick and you're
like what the hell are these two doing
together the one I'm watching now I
think there's a deaf couple okay and
then the guy like the 18-year-old that
moves to Thailand or something and has
to ride on the back of a yak it's a
awesome and so she so he would would
wear the hat and he's like Jasmine think
you know that guy he talks about Jasmine
all the time and she's like I want you
to put me in the nicest place here those
two I could watch them it's fast it's a
human experiment it's so fasc I could
watch them to if if they were on live
stream 24/7 I wouldn't be here right now
I would never leave my place they're the
most interesting couple I've ever they
go from mortal enemies at 3:00 to 4:00
he's proposing for the fifth time mhm
it's it's proper unhinged people love
and you know what I like about it it
makes me feel the comfort of the
insanity I grew up with without actually
having to be like I have control of it I
could turn it on I could turn it off wow
I can there he goes again that's so
smart
deep czy I can stop my life yeah it's
like you [__] [__] you you piece
of [__] and I could be like that's you
that's you closing and locking your
bedroom door right there yeah yeah there
you go no thank you Mom what are you
sleeping
in uh so I have the this again you're
right this is I have these uh shorts
they're like either jeans or $5,000
pajamas yeah exactly
there am I taking my sneakers on or uh I
I sleep in these like what is it called
bamboo shorts but they're only like 20
bucks or whatever on Amazon I have like
30 pair and I I they're the gift
breathable amazing they're the gift I
give to everyone when it's like a time
to give a gift and I give it to them and
they're they're always like they're the
only thing I sleep in huh and it's one
like I don't know if you know the you do
underwear under them or just the shorts
just the shorts and so you know uh
writing that
down they're amazing so you know the
pitsky effect which is uh Christina P
She has thing called the pitsky effect
where it's like uh uh you know her and
Tom used the same phone charger for like
eight years even when they were like
doing very well and then one day we we
were going through the same thing right
and then one day they're like oh we can
buy three phone chargers like you don't
realize the things you've held so you're
like oh a phone charger and then you're
like okay well they're now nine bucks we
can afford a th000 charger right so with
those shorts I'm like I used to be like
oh man my shorts are in the laundry this
and and then one day on [__] Amazon I
saw like the counter thing where you
could buy and I'm like you could drag
this all way to 30 and now I just have
30 [__] pair of them and it's never
not there's never not a clean one it's
it's a life Cher you sleep with your
socks on get the [__] out of here do I
sleep with my socks on are you [__] L
who sleeps with their socks on in here
anybody no dude that's insane I'd I'd
literally it's the same thing to me as
sleeping in like a [__] uh a North
Face jacket yeah no sleep with a socks
on is a lunatic move that's the first
time you've Challen that any guess has
challenged the whole room like who when
here does that F
you uh do you have a goto karaoke song
uh you know again with [__] Tom and
Christina I never I was a no karaoke guy
and then at Christina P's birthday uh
they had karaoke and you know I felt
like a loser for not doing it cuz it was
like people were doing and it was also
like they had like little rooms so it
wasn't like everybody so um what' you do
I did uh Bon Jo
V uh I pr yeah yeah yeah slip notot wait
and bed
yeah it's
like I'm like everybody ready happy
birthday Christina this one's for
you open the pit up I respect it and
then after that I did um Forgot About
Dre I did M&M's part and my friend did
uh yeah my boy [__] did uh the uh Dre
part I I think see I think rapping is
easy because it was just like talking I
didn't have to you know what I mean you
don't got to be on it and I knew that I
knew I knew M&M's [__] part down well
you dance at a wedding
uh it depends if it hits me I when I was
drinking I would dance I was yeah yeah
uh now it has to really hit me you know
like at at Jaime's wedding she had the
right kind of like they she had a band
and they were doing like kind of 90s
music and this and it you know and she
wanted people D like I would be outside
like [__] you know I forget if I was
smoking Sal but like trying to smoke or
whatever and they had people coming and
be like Jamie wants everyone
inside so like you know sometimes it
hits me and then there's other where
it's like get the [__] out of here like
I'm I'm not dancing to this [__] you
drinking coffee any coffee I do Zero
caffeine Zero caffeine Zero caffeine of
any kind I drink so again I used to do
[__] Molly Coke ketamine for days
straight and I was fine if I drink one
coffee
I'm it's it and Dr Drew is actually
talking to me about this but he's like
people have different ways of digesting
it where like some people it's gone in
45 minutes and other people it's like
days yeah and that's what happens with
me like I drink [__] you know coffee
and I'm buzzing okay I
mean um
yeah it can go either way you get cash
back when you make a purchase will you
take will you get money no I never have
I I don't even know do you I try and get
out of there as fast as possible do you
have any credit cards now do you yeah
yeah yeah eventually I got one okay yeah
MX I only have one One credit card One
credit card MX Visa what are you using I
don't know you don't know said no that's
crazy well listen because of my [__]
manager it's never not worked you know
he just I just got it in my pocket and
whenever I need to buy something I just
uh let me see what we got here New York
kid always oh yeah whoa
whoa uh we'll blur it's a VISA no no no
it's a MasterCard all right okay not bad
got a MasterCard who's cutting the hair
uh so also wait no wallet just lose
cards in his pocket no wallet ever no no
wallet CU if I lose the wallet I lose
everything if I lose one card I lose one
card the uh what was the question before
what' you say the haircut hair so the
one before this one I did and then and
then the the this kid's [__] trash I
don't know what your own hair yeah yeah
I just I have you know I used to have a
thing where I'd grow out my hair for
like you see on Sopranos so I have long
hair and then short and then long so I
would just grow out my hair cuz I hated
going to get a haircut and I was
partying so much and then one day I
would just shave it into the toilet I
just [__] shave my head and then it
was he's in jail yeah yeah I cut your ha
cutting your hair in an apartment with
no furniture you're
trash I was like I was on the lamb when
I cut my hairing his beard and [__] it
was just getting like a little too long
where it would be in my [__] face and
I'm like well I don't need this and I
just [__] combed it down and I just
[__] chop chop chop here I didn't do
I didn't do the sides of the back but I
just got the front out of the way who
cut the last one did you go to a place I
went to like a legit Place yeah yeah
before I came here before I came to New
York I was like all right I wantan to
because you know what it was I hadn't
done my hair in like a year and my uh
goddaughter or my my uh sorry my niece
was getting baptized so I'm like I'm
going to have to [__] do my hair for
the first time and I'm like what does
that even look like right now cuz it had
been since my friend's wedding over a
year ago and uh doesn't have his hair in
a year yeah yeah I'm just a hat guy I'm
just a big hat guy or like this like I
just got out of the shower and I was
like yeah [__] it looks pretty good
though he lives on he lives on his own
terms man I tell you I respect the [__]
out of it it's [__] awesome that's
what happens when you get the kid a lock
for door yeah he makes his own [__]
possibilities any maybe I'll do my hair
maybe I won't do my hair yeah do you own
any suits you have suits at the house
yeah here you this is going to [__]
blow your mind I got a custom tux for my
friend's wedding I got with my [__]
name in the jacket a custom I got a
custom it was only like 600 bucks it was
one of these places over here but yeah I
got I got a custom the
sushi you want to tux for some sushi I
got a uh yes so I had a custom and then
I have like one or two but you want to
hear trash so that time time when I
we've heard it already just just for the
just so we know uh I when I went to that
Vegas for the [__] two weeks and I
stayed for a year and a half I came back
and shortly after coming back was one of
my friends weddings so I'm like okay no
problem like you I'll see you there I
put the tux on and I hadn't put that tux
on in I don't know 3 four years and it
was huge I'm walking and there's no belt
loop in a tux I'm walking around my and
I put the tux on 30 minutes before the
wedding like before I got I'm like oh my
God walking around his wedding for 3
hours holding my [__] pants up and
then dancing that night and one of the
[__] groomsmen finally goes hey we
have suspenders on under do you want
this and I put the suspenders on it was
like the greatest [__] lifer like oh my
God thank like a guy from the
depression holy [__] ladies and
gentlemen the podcast is not today pal
at ymh Studios Mr Robert iser buddy yeah
thanks [__] fantastic thank you for
having absolutely [__] fantastic
anything you want the folks AR there to
know you want to hit with no yeah when
you guys are in Austin come by
man come
hang we're all over the you know
anywhere you find your stuff whatever
they say I'm not I'm not I don't know
Tom is the business guy he's spending
[__] 52,000 on dinner I'm just here
to [__] have a good time you know
don't tell him he told you
that it was
5,200 kby what do you got for him uh
guys we're all over the road uh like we
said added shows in Philly that's more
than halfway sold out get those tickets
that's going to go for sure
uh fourth show out in Chicago get those
[__] tickets third show out in
Toronto get those [__] tickets
everything else is almost sold out we
[__] love you thank you so much
Robert we love you buddy thank you for
coming in thank you for having me man it
was great it was fun gang we love you
too and we'll see you next week peace